good afternoon uh thank you everyone for
coming i appreciate you making time this
afternoon to to come on down
nevadans are following the daily news
updates as it relates to the
fall surge that we're experiencing with
covet across the country and around the
globe right now
i am not here to announce a new
directive or more restrictions
i want to be able to continue on the
path that we are currently on
and that's going to take everyone's help
in order to do that i wanted to update
nevadans on the current status of cobit
19
in nevada and how what we do as nevadans
in the coming days and weeks
will make the difference on the path
that we take
this pandemic has been exhausting and
overwhelming
but our mission must remain unchanged
we need to follow public health
recommendations
mitigate the spread to prevent more
deaths and protect our health care
system from being overwhelmed with cases
we need to save our economy and protect
our businesses
and we need to get our kids back in
school in the safest way possible
superintendent ebert and the team are
working on this
as we speak
the national situation nationally we
have surpassed
8 million known cases and last friday
the u.s had
70 thousand new infections in one day
the highest single one day total since
july
sadly there have been over two hundred
and twenty thousand deaths
to this day and there is a story
behind every one of those deaths a name
and a family however we are also seeing
signs uh that treatment nationally has
improved
reducing the percentage number of lives
that are lost as a result
of covid19 there are a number of states
seeing concerning increases in cases
and in their hospitalizations one of the
biggest challenges is the spread of
which this
is the speed at which this virus spreads
and impacts hospitals
one day is fine you're not at the
capacity
and a week later you can be bumping up
against your capacity for beds
and for icu units hospitals can then be
teetering on the edge of having to turn
patients away
we have to avoid that in nevada
we are also seeing a significant trend
in new cases
according to this week's white house
covet 19 task force
we are in the red zone for cases and we
have the 24th highest rate
in the country we are in the orange zone
for test positivity with the 16th
highest
rate in the country our 14-day test
positivity rate
is currently 9.1
as of today for the most recent
seven-day period
cases are growing at a rate of 0.8
or 666 additional cases per day
for comparison the growth rate for the
seven day period at the beginning of
september
was 0.5 and 332 cases per day
half of what it is today nevada is not
currently experiencing concerns related
to hospitalization saturation
or critical infrastructure overload
based on covid patients
with relative demand placed on hospitals
hospitals by covid
at approximately 10 percent
but hospitalizations are steadily
increasing in nevada
things can change over a matter days
matter of days
especially in flu season flu shots are
more important this year than ever
the combination of flu and the covid
could place an enormous burden
on our hospitals we cannot let that
happen
please do your part get a vaccine
for the flu i also want to thank our
health care workers our frontline
workers who have worked so hard
fighting this virus they never got a
stay-at-home order
we owe it to them to protect their
health and honor the service that they
provide
situation we're now facing and is of
extreme importance
is what we're calling overcoming covet
fatigue
in nevada and in the country
back in the spring and while it seems
like it was a decade ago
scientists and public health officials
were saying it would take
15 days to flatten the curve i remember
vice president pence holding up a sign
and then it was 30 days to flatten the
curve
coven wasn't supposed to last this long
we all feel coveted fatigue and it
results in riskier behavior
and complacency we cannot let that
happen
unfortunately this virus doesn't get
fatigued
it's alive and well it's that simple
we can't get tired because the virus
isn't tired
and if we allow the fatigue to take over
over us
the virus will spread you need to do
your part
we're face covering practice social
distancing
wash your hands get a flu shot
get a covet test i know that the
behavior
certain officials at the highest level
of our government run contrary
to the public health experts they create
a sense that the pandemic is over
rounding the corner or that masks don't
work
it creates division
i want to be clear we need to be united
the enemy is the disease it's not each
other
the enemy is the disease not
each other the most important tool
in fighting this pandemic is you
nevada's your behavior our behaviors
it's our willingness to mask up to
socially distance
to make sacrifices that's how we get
through this
that's how we get through this together
that's what i wanted to address all of
you today to let you know that we are
beginning
just very beginning to see an alarming
trend
in the number of cases and
hospitalizations in nevada
but more importantly i want to remind
all of you
and this is very important we are not
helpless
we have the power to change the
trajectory
you have the power to change your
trajectory we all need to do our part
to make this happen if i had a dial in
my office where i could
turn it down and control the cases i'd
turn it all the way to the bottom
and be able to move on but i don't have
a dial like that
nevadans control the dial through their
willingness to adapt
and adopt public health measures
again what we do as nevadans in the
coming days
and weeks will determine the impact of a
surge
we are not helpless against this
pandemic
we can fight this pandemic if we all
work together
united here's my appeal to all of you
if like me you want to open more and not
less
if you want to get your kids back in
school back in the classroom
if you want people be able to return to
their jobs
this is what it takes this mask
this is the key in a situation
that can seem complex it's really very
simple
we can overcome this disease we can
fight back
so here's what we need to do nevada
compliance with our face covering
protocols
social distancing individual hygiene
avoiding crowds in public and private
gatherings
if you're sick or you have been exposed
please isolate yourself and stay
home get a test if you had a positive
contact or symptoms
you can get a test across the street the
turnaround time has been
shortened drastically do your part
to help us fight this disease i want to
update you on a couple other things
before i open up to a couple questions
deter has begun processing and paying
the additional unemployment insurance
money through the federal lost wages
program
payments are being made right now for
claimants who are eligible for this
program
last week nevada dhhs
submitted the state's covet vaccination
plan to the cdc
i'm extremely proud of the work that's
been done on this plan
and i look forward to providing an
update with the state vaccination team
next week that concludes my repair
prepared remarks if anybody has any
questions i'd be happy to take a couple
if you want to go to the microphone
governor joe bartels with 13 action news
uh could you explain a little bit more
about the
uh the game plan for vaccinations i know
that there was some deadlines that were
required to talk a little bit more about
if and when a vaccine becomes available
what that may look like in terms of
distribution the vaccine for covet is
reposable vaccine for
flu um for cova yeah yeah
uh we are on regular contacts with the
vice president's task force
ezra lasakovit there is still no
hard date our company in terms of which
company is going to
come with the vaccine first or what date
that vaccine will be made available
it's going to be an extremely limited
supply
at the beginning in the immediate month
or so following that
it's our intent to make the vaccine
available to our front line workers our
health care workers
our vulnerable population first before
we make it available to the general
public
uh we'll be able to give a lot more
details on the distribution of the
vaccine next week
when we have that press conference uh
we're doing what we can to get the
infrastructure in place
in terms of the equipment you know you
need especially cold
refrigeration to get that handle and
we'll make that all available next week
thank you governor orkomana with channel
8 here in vegas
uh you mentioned talking with joan eber
about possible plans for school can you
elaborate on that a little bit more
sure uh jonah and i talk regularly and
uh hey i'm a dad i know what it's like
that your kids aren't in school
it would be my goal that we get our kids
back in the classrooms as quickly as we
can
get them back in the classrooms our
school boards are
working with our health districts and i
believe 16 of our 17 counties we have
some attendance in classrooms right now
uh clark
is currently the one that doesn't have
any kids in school
it's my hope that uh the groups can work
together the school board along with our
health officials
to come up with a plan that we can get
our kids back into classrooms
as soon as possible for their education
that would be my wish and
i know the school board i've talked to
superintendent
jarrah and i've talked to a couple of
school board members
uh i know they've got some meetings
upcoming to deal with this
and hopefully they'll be able to come
into an agreement consensus with the
parents
and with the faculty
governor enzo mourinho fox 5 news you
talked about nevada being in the red
zone
at what point do you think you would
need to re-implement some of the
restrictions that have been list that
have been lifted in the in the past
recent weeks and months i hope we never
get to that
point uh ultimately that point is going
to be determined based on the behavior
and the the assistance that i get from
every nevada
we're looking at trends more than
specific numbers that have to be hit
benchmarks uh the trends that's why i'm
here the trends are beginning to become
alarming
when you see the cases increasing we
expected the cases to increase a little
bit
as we uh released some of the pressure
if you want to call it that and we
eliminated some of the restrictions
and got people out more we expected to
go out a little bit
i am uh aware and i'm
i'm very happy about the fact that we're
compliance with our mask wearing is
becoming larger
which is very very good but this is
something that i know the school boards
are looking at
when they talk about opening up our
schools and we're going to have to
continue
to address these issues with the task
force
and determine with the health experts if
we hit that point we're not at that
point now
i don't want to get to that point and
every single nevadan can make a
difference on us getting to that point
or not
the behavior of each and every one of us
can make the difference of whether
or not we're going to trigger that and
force more restrictions and i don't want
to see that happen so we're working
to loosen things up more and get people
back to
what their new normal is governor
another quick one a lot of people
are excited about halloween their kids
wanting to get out
do you have anything to say about the
upcoming holiday as far as
people complying and doing what you just
said wearing the mask
and and social distancing and all that
do you have any comment on the upcoming
uh well halloween is going to be tough i
mean you can still have
halloween but you have to have it safely
and i ask you to follow local
restrictions
and guidelines when it comes to
halloween i know the first lady and i
had a great time last year for our first
year in the mansion to distribute candy
to the kids we probably had 1500 kids
come by
we're not having that this year
unfortunately because you can't social
distance that many people
but i encourage everyone to follow their
local jurisdictions and health
guidelines when it comes to cal
to halloween and hopefully the parents
will be able to
make a halloween experience or they can
do it virtually for the kids
thank you governor victor jake's las
vegas review journal a couple weeks ago
ccsd put out some attendance numbers for
distance learning and showed
african-american and hispanic students
were much less likely to show up on a
given day for class
are you concerned that continued
distance learning isn't going to
exacerbate
racial disparities of student
achievement i'm concerned that
distance education as a whole is going
to exacerbate
you know the learning
curve if we want to call it that it is
my desire
to get kids back in a classroom i don't
think there's any denying it
education works better when kids are in
classrooms
that being said i want him in classrooms
safely
and i've asked the superintendent and
spoken with him numerous times over the
past week or so to work with our health
districts
and try to come up with a plan that we
can get kids back in the classroom
safely and all kids will be able to
experience
the regular activities of classroom i
mean i feel terrible that kids seniors
are not able to have their homecoming or
their prom
or to participate in events that might
help them get college scholarships later
uh that's very very difficult and i know
they're
missing out on experiences that
everybody here had
as a senior in high school as or if
you've got kids that they have when
they're in school
being honest kids want to get back and
they want to see their friends they
haven't seen them all summer
they want to see their friends and i
want them to be able to see their
friends but i want to be able to see
their sons
friends safely in the classroom and
superintendent ebert
has taken the lead to hopefully get us
there quickly i've got a system like
john traynor
ksmv yesterday ran into a
husband a wife and an 18 year old trying
to get money to buy food
still waiting for pua assistance they've
been told they qualify
that the money should be released to
them it hasn't been
i know you've gotten this question a lot
but are there guarantees you can make
the people now waiting for money
that they're going to get that money the
guarantee that i can make is that i've
got a staff that's working overtime
we've added a lot more people to
adjudicate these claims you've seen the
press conference that the u.s attorney
had
neutral chanuch about the fraud that
related we sent out
a lot of letters this week about
fraudulent claims
you saw the maserati that was stopped on
the strip here and it
i don't know 60 70 000 in cash and two
dozen
unemployment cards in it we're trying to
protect
the sanctity of the the system and so
much as employers
whatever we end up paying we have to
borrow money from the federal government
employers are going to have to make up
that deficit we have to pay that money
back
and that money is going to come back
through future unemployment
benefits that are paid to the state and
we need to protect that the wages are
being paid i know
we're having a problem with uh some
claimants but the claimants that we have
are ones that have got some mitigating
factor that we're trying to work through
one at a time and we've got every
available
state employee working on these claims
uh one more question for you test
positivity rate you said just over nine
percent
johns hopkins has our number closer to
46 percent yeah
yeah we i had staff talk to johns
hopkins i appreciate it i saw that
number
apparently they had a mix-up when we
changed the dashboard
from what it was to what it is now when
they grab some wrong figures and put
them together
but i'm hopeful that they'll come up
with a correction to that in the next
few days but they agreed to explain to
them i had our
dhs just called them and explained how
we got to our rate and they agree it's
just a matter of
communicating it to the right people
great well thank you everyone for coming
out thanks everybody stay safe
and the other thing i'd like to
encourage everybody to do is vote
we're in the middle of early voting mail
your vote in drop your vote off
go to early voting or vote on election
day but whatever you do and whoever your
candidate is please
turn out and vote this year and get a
flu vaccine thank you all